hola bienvenidos en este vídeo vamos a
volver a tomar una moneda justa
justa
y vamos a hacer ahora no 4 si no vamos a
hacer 5 volados 5 volados 5 lanzamientos
de nuestra moneda justa y esencialmente
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
preguntarme por cuál es la probabilidad
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
exactamente
si marco exactamente
águilas
tres águilas o si lo quieren pensar como
tres caras de cara o cruz cualquiera de
las dos que me salgan tres veces el
mismo dibujo en la moneda y bueno
empecemos por preguntarnos cuántas
posibilidades hay cuántos distintos
resultados puedo tener pues en el primer
volado a ver tengo 1 2 3 4 5 volados en
el primer volado tengo dos posibilidades
aquí lo soy
igualmente probables en el segundo
también tengo todos en el tercero
también tengo dos en el cuarto también
tengo dos y en el quinto también tengo
dos en todos puede obtener águila o sol
pero no las dos y cuánto es esto esto es
2 por 2 son 4 por 2 son 8 por 2 16 por 2
32 estos dos a la quinta que es 32
posibilidades distintas o si quieren
pensarlo así 32 resultados
resultados distintos pero todos son
igualmente probables ok y de esos
resultados cuales contienen exactamente
3 águilas podría en principio hacer una
lista con las 32 resultados y ver de
esos cuales contienen exactamente 3
águilas pero mejor vamos a hacer lo que
estamos explorando en los vídeos pasados
que es contar de cuántas maneras puedo
obtener estas tres águilas vamos a
pensar en estas tres águilas como águila
como allí la ve
y como allí la c qué
en si no quiero hacer ninguna distinción
entre ellas vamos a ver que todas las
águilas son iguales
de otro modo lo que va a pasar es que
resultados como
allí la a águila de enlace y luego no sé
sol sol sería fundamentalmente distinto
a allí la vez allí la águila ce sol sol
y realmente son exactamente lo mismo
porque como podríamos decir
coloquialmente todas las águilas son
creadas iguales así que esto sólo es una
anotación pero bueno vamos a tratar de
contar cuántas de estas águilas
tendríamos cómo podría colocar estas
tres águilas en cinco volados así que si
piensa en missing como la 2 1 2 3 4 5 si
pienso en mis 5 volados que puedo hacer
pues el primer águila vamos a pensar en
águila el águila la puedo colocar en
cualquiera de estos cinco lugares
si quisiera acomodar estas tres águilas
en estos cinco lugares entonces el
águila puede estar en cualquiera de
cinco el águila ve pues ayudar ya está
ocupando uno así que para águila ve sólo
cabe en cuatro lugares posibles y que
habiéndose pues un espacio está ocupado
por águila y otro espacio está ocupado
por águila ve por lo tanto para águilas
sólo hay tres lugares disponibles así
que el número total de formas de
acomodar estas tres águilas que son
distintas
es 5 x 4 20 por 3 que es 60 ahora 60 es
un número muy grande habíamos dicho que
sólo habían 32 resultados distintos y la
razón para ello es que estamos contando
doble o es más es más de doble pero
vamos a ver por ejemplo podría ser que
allí la hubiera estado en este espacio
que allí la ve hubiera estado no sé aquí
y que allí las es sólo para variar un
poco estuviera acá y entonces esta
situación la estamos contando como una
situación distinta a que aquí la hubiera
aparecido aquí mientras que águila se
hubiera aparecido aquí y águila de
hubiera aparecido acá a pesar de que
fundamentalmente es el mismo resultado
sería sol águila águila sol águila y
sería lo mismo acá sol águila águila sol
águila así que tenemos que dividir entre
todas las formas de reacomodar estas
tres águilas en tres lugares disponibles
y como hago esto pues veamos tengo tres
lugares disponibles uno
3 y tengo tres objetos voy a hacerlo
todo con rojo tengo águila águila ve y
águila si ahora alguien la puede estar
en cualquiera de estos tres lugares por
ejemplo podría estar en este primero así
que vamos a colocarla en cualquiera de
tres lugares disponibles águila ve puede
estar en cualquiera de los dos lugares
que me sobran
y águilas sólo puede estar en uno de los
lugares que no sobran por lo tanto el
número de formas de reacomodar estas
tres águilas en tres lugares dados
por 2 por 1 o sea 6
de modo que para obtener la verdadera
cantidad de colocar tres águilas en tres
lugares distintos
tengo que dividir estos 60 es decir
vamos a anotar todo esto vamos a ponerlo
con azul cielo
el número
de formas
de obtener
y obtener
exactamente tres águilas
exactamente
tres águilas
uy la letra y al final
el número de formas de obtener
exactamente tres águilas es que pues
serían estos 60 que son 5 por 4 por 3 5
por 4 por 3 y eso es simplemente de
acomodar las en tres lugares y ahora
tengo que dividir entre el número de
permutaciones que puedo aplicar dentro
de estos tres lugares que es este número
de aquí entre 3 por 2
y cuánto es esto el numerador ya lo
calculamos de 65 por 4 por 13 63 por dos
por uno es 6 60 entre 6 es 10 por lo
tanto hay 10 formas de obtener
exactamente 3 águilas y hay 32
resultados distintos que puedo obtener
en 5 volados por lo tanto la
probabilidad de obtener exactamente 3
águilas son el número de eventos
favorables que son 10 dividido entre el
número de resultados posibles que es 32
el resultado sería 10 entre 32 o si
prefieren si reducen la fracción esto es
lo mismo que 5 entre 16
ese sería nuestro resultado